foreign
[Music]
and here are your daughters Angela and
Catherine about seven hours ago and
that's the last information we have
hey hey you found her we Catherine doing
our day in those woods yo just walk in
and walking
Angela can you tell your dad how long
you were gone a few hours
maybe you've been gone three days
yeah
[Music]
what'd you say I didn't say nothing
I thought I heard you say something
hey baby
you okay
wherever those girls went they brought
something back with him the body and the
blood of Jesus Christ
in the blood
Catherine body in the blood
the body in the blood the body and the
blood countries
have you ever seen anything like this
no but there are people out there
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
experience with possession yes more than
that flag
I believe you can help get our girls
back
so citizen is a ritual culture every
religion they all use different methods
it's going to take all of them
[Music]
we've met before
[Applause]
[Music]
what did you do
is that Catherine's heartbeat they're
beating in sync
[Music]
there's something wrong with the skull
something doesn't feel right
[Music]
so if you what happened
if there's something here
that's not meant to be
[Applause]
I saw none
what are you doing
she's standing
this thing it's come back for me
this demon was once an angel
rejected by God
stripped of power
that power back
it's okay to be scared
I'm scared too
you send that thing back to hell
[Music]
foreign
ER
on Charter from Romania to London
shipping private crates
unknown
out at Sea with no land in sight
he's a doctor
you dress like a learned man University
of Cambridge I know my way around the
boat our Charter has agreed to pay upon
us for timely arrival number
let me show you the ship this here is
huckleberry
we don't come with like this to give
these clear
[Applause]
something ripped to Pat the animals
all the livestock this looks like a bite
search the ship everywhere
evil isn't bored
[Music]
powerful evil
in night it rings our blood
we call him the you know
he's coming
see the size of that bloody thing
[Music]
he is on this ship which means we will
never leave
the devil is real
may God have mercy on us all
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I heard it again
no more nightmares tonight okay champ
[Music]
this is getting ridiculous
this is an old house
there's bound to be bumps in the night
[Music]
oh
Peter Drew this yes is he all right
Peter has an overactive imagination
[Music]
no more that's right
you know I wish I had someone I could
talk to about the things that were
happening in my house Mom
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Peter sometimes
you have to make hard decisions to
protect your family
what is that
the banging
[Music]
okay
you don't hear anything Peter
I'm just going to get you into trouble
one day
[Music]
the cancer is still spreading I'm afraid
there's nothing else we can do there is
one person who might be able to help our
program is a two-pronged treatment
outside Mexico City the results have
been stunning she saved my life
Michael
you're in very good hands with us
after that what happens then your whole
life happens today John Kramer
according to these scans the tumor was
never removed how much gun do I have
months at best I still have a lot of
work that needs to be done
[Music]
hello everyone it's time to play a game
you all pretended to kill me the one I
have planned for each of you is very
real
[Music]
no sound
only thing I have not provided is your
anesthetic but trust me
you will want to remain alert
[Music]
of all the men to cheat you picked John
Kramer please don't hesitate place a big
enough piece of your cerebral tissue
into the glass enzyme tank this will
save your life
which is not retribution it's a
Reawakening
[Music]
please
little dog the choice is yours
I've found something
I've looked at it from Every Which Way I
Am the smartest person I ever met and I
can't figure it out so I came to the
second you are up to something my friend
I've seen a million is so cold
sake
to a Saiyan spot the con I can't
detective you are here to discredit me
but I can talk to the Dead
is
if one wants to be heard we are here
listening
um
Felicia
what is happening
[Applause]
[Music]
the concert is here somebody is dead no
one should leave this place until I know
who did it a ghost killed her
there must be a rational answer for all
of this
just admit that you are up against
something bigger than you no
[Music]
you were saying
something in this house tried to kill me
don't look at me like I'm suspect we're
old friends every murderer is someone is
all friends
no one shall leave until I find if the
living have been killed by the dead
you have been hiding here all this time
who are you talking to
[Music]
me
Alice engaging with trolls is like the
worst possible use of your energy
[Music]
since you joined BuzzFeed your art got
super lame and you die in a fire
don't judge me or sometimes you gotta
troll the trolls
[Music]
laughs
foreign
belongs to you really think a weird
account is haunting your apartment
here David he was only 10 and his mother
went insane Linda Landers
he is your son
Dr Landers
[Music]
oh my God
you've seen my son David I'm having you
what does he want ask him yourself
[Music]
hi this is Mike I was just calling to
see if that job that you offered was
still available yes the security guard I
will take anything
this place was huge in the 80s with the
kids they shut it down years ago the
owner's just not ready to let it go yet
I will work and you will sleep I
understand
all you have to do is keep your eyes on
the monitor
welcome to Freddy Fazbear's where
fantasy and fun
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
we must be new security guards can I uh
help you officer have you met them yet
[Applause]
bam
[Music]
in the 80s kids went missing
the police searched Freddy's top to
bottom hello
[Music]
they never found them
that's why the place shut down
there are ghost children possessing
giant robots
thanks for the heads up
technically they're animatronics
what do they want they want to make
heart like them Bobby
tell me how to stop them
too late
Bobby go
where to
why do I always get the weirdos
are you ready
we're ready to forget the further once
and for all
[Music]
my brain just been foggy past few years
all I ever wanted was to be a good dad
Dalton
all right
[Music]
did you ever try and get help I'm just
trying to push through
you drive Dalton to college you still
have a few weeks before your students
show up right just an idea to reconnect
I know it's been tough with you too
[Music]
the balance of light and dark is what
we're after you're an art school I take
it yeah you go here too yes
draw an experience that defines you when
I was 10.
it was in a coma
but I don't even remember being sick
sink deep into your memory
and let's see what life can find
I'm seeing crazy stuff
I think these drawings could be Clues
from my past so much you don't know and
I was too scared to tell you the truth
our family has been keeping secrets they
suppressed our memories but I can still
feel something following us there's only
one way to find out
I feel like I'm getting closer to
something
's getting closer to me
when you awaken the Dead the further you
travel the riskier your journey will
become
huh no please what's my mom's
Remembrance Day I just want to forget
about it huh
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll do it
cannot go for more than 90 seconds am I
clear what happens after 90 seconds
don't want to stay
like the candle to open the door
blow it out to close it
put your hand on it
now say
talk to me
[Applause]
[Music]
talk to me
what does the hand feel like
felt amazing I could see and feel
everything on the other side
so my mom she was trying to reach out
Point video
still been seeing stuff you've been
saying stuff
what if we open the door but we didn't
shut it
oh my God they followed us
they're not gonna stop you're never
gonna stop
I like you
when my son and I moved in here
it wasn't as warm as we hoped
okay I'm gonna light a vanilla candle
and it's going to be a game changer
and after midnight the house comes alive
this place is haunted
we need your help
it's time to assemble the Dream Team
we find someone who can communicate with
these ghosts
people used to eat here I told you she's
good it's a dining room I found a
professor who else wanted mansions I've
been dying to go to this place for years
Mr
clerks around every corner
I
[Music]
can show you what happened but it will
cost you
three dollars
what Mom sorry robbery who said that
you're not that scary you're really not
terrifying can you turn around just
while I finish this up thank you
guys is anybody else seeing this yeah
I'm seeing it
hold on
drink
here for eternity
you're all in for a treat
no no
no no no
oh come on
[Music]
when there are scary things we don't
understand
our minds try to
fill in the blanks
Sometimes the best thing to do is to
face it
so this light is going to be completely
solid like it is right now
then gradually it's going to start
flashing until it's totally dark
so you can see that there's nothing to
be afraid of
okay
see that's not so scary is it
just you you sister and me
you're doing okay
it's not real
it's okay
it's all just in your head
[Music]
oh
Kitty or something in my room
you believe me
don't you
there's no such thing as monsters you
need to grow up
I'm serious Sawyer I need to be alone
you're both having these these
manifestations
what is this what is this supposed to be
a thing that comes for your kids when
you're not paying attention
[Applause]
dad you have to listen to me okay
I'm listening
sweetheart let me handle it
[Music]
a town knows its Secrets
the town knows how to hide them too
she sleeps with the worms under the
ground we sat outside don't make a sound
bad enough nine times
nine times don't answer your door close
all your blinds
[Music]
I thought that was just an old ghost
story where do you think those stories
come from
I don't know maybe she's still alive
someone we should call the cops
what the hell is going on here
hippie
what are you doing
after all she's been through she's
trying to make up for what happened to
her you mean how Wes for brainwashed her
and made her come after us no one's
blaming Jill for that
no one
Jill
Dr Taylor yeah yeah we need him in
custody ASAP I checked the DNA we got
it had a strain of t-virus in it you're
kidding I found the connection between
the folks that were infected they all
visited Alcatraz recently foreign
it's time we debuted our
creation
they turn fast and without being bitten
I'm Rebecca what do you want me to tell
them someone accessed the dod server
they managed to steal data on Leon Jill
Chris and Claire you think this might
have something to do with the operon now
most likely
I'm going to use my virus to clean the
Slate Dylan
you're nothing more than pause
I can't be good
yeah
[Music]
excuse me
he's all yours
final stage now that there is no justice
[Music]
foreign
I don't normally I get visits from
former students
I just I needed to tell you
how sorry I am for um about what
happened
[Music]
sorry uh let me just answer that
hello
what wait slow down
oh my God that's horrible is he
[Music]
really okay
if someone just assaulted our vice
principal in the parking lot
no Benson what you want you don't know
me
[Music]
what oh are you doing this
because Randy I've been watching you you
are 20 years old and you are already
more pathetic than every person in this
God forsaken town and then bugs me
there's something about you there's
something fixable let me know when you
were standing there watching me
waiting for me to kill you
that was the only thing I believed
that if I'm gonna help you then I can't
have you getting in my way
because you're forced
forces to hurt you
I need you to work with me not against
me
I'm doing this for you all good
please
[Music]
Square
or Square
[Music]
on June 16th
wait hold up I know I left this door see
the horror film
preview audiences are calling a killer
experience
no thank you probably runs on racism
going to die
it was always the first
you've sacrificed the person you deemed
the blackest guys I can prove them not
the blackest prove it I thought black
Twitter was a type of seasoning I like
Jimmy Fallon without the roots and wrong
I voted for Trump
what
twice
your time is up it's time to die
got a cops
[Music]
[Applause]
enough
[Music]
time
can we just go lock the doors get down
I'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you